very much thank you
thank you very much andy that's enough
went on a little long but still
appreciate it
that's how it happens the fans won't let
you start the show
you're right they love you so much or
maybe they just don't want the show to
start
well let's prefer the first ex yeah yeah
they love you so much
good to see you andy yeah good to see
you having a mass
now again broadcasting from the lovely
largo theater here in los angeles yep
historic
historic historic theater great theater
and uh
and we love being in this space and we
have a wonderful show
just a wonderful show tonight jim
gaffigan
is here and he will teach us to laugh
again
see what i did there i know i had a
stroke
you know i am excited about the program
uh but i think we're all trying to find
ways that we can help aren't we andy
i know i am that's kind of a well i am
too don't say it like i'm not
i am too you're not known for caring
about other people
maybe not in the past but it's a new
thing i'm trying turning over a new leaf
yes it's like a fad diet i'm gonna try
caring about other humans right
kovid made me care the conan o'brien
story
well yes covid uh i care i want to help
any way i can
and that leads me to this little thing i
want to mention
i'm not sure if you saw this uh story in
the news but
because of the coronavirus this is true
buckingham palace has started
laying off staff due to the lack of
tourism wow laying off staff which is
very sad
yeah so i thought it might be nice to
help out one of those recently laid off
workers so tonight
we've hired one of the queen's guard as
a paid audience member
that's right and there he is and uh tell
us how's it going reginald
uh you liking america
okay well queen's guard tough audience
but
i think i'll get him with some of these
monologue jokes what do you think andy
yeah let him have it
all right here we go hey check this out
uh yesterday amazon founder jeff bezos
made
13 billion dollars in one day yeah
unfortunately most that money was stolen
off his porch
[Laughter]
cause like the boxes get stolen the
boxes at amazon get stolen
and that's why okay listen to this
president trump
has ordered the chinese consulate in
houston to be closed
uh-huh in response chinese diplomats
said oh no
we don't get to hang out in houston in
august
right he's miserably out there it's very
any and humid
and humid yeah yeah so the chinese don't
care
they don't care about not no okay here
we go
not a bad punishment for the chinese
here we go
iceland has a new service where people
can go to a designated location and
scream out their frustrations
yeah we have something like that here in
america
it's called costco
man this guy's he's tough okay here we
go nfl players are warning that the
season may not happen
yeah after hearing this jets fans said
hey
do what you got to do
hit jets are very bad they suck they
suck and that's suck
okay andy this one's gonna get him this
is gonna all right let him hang out
disney world has a banned its guests
from eating
while walking yeah so they don't pull
off their masks as they stroll
yeah disney said we want our guests to
get diabetes or covid
but not both
wow ah man you know andy i should have
seen this coming
the queen's guard are famously trained
to not react to anything
i don't think anyone in the world can
make him laugh
yeah i mean making those guys laugh
is harder than a week old biscuit